if you happen to be in Iowa this week
you can catch a satanic altar uh put up
on display at the Iowa state capital
this was put up by the satanic temple
the co-founder of the satanic temple
says this is a symbol of the satanists
right to religious
freedom of course Satanism is not
entitled to any rights whatsoever and
the founding fathers certainly wouldn't
have thought so and no no one even the
great Defenders of religious freedom not
so long ago would have ever defended
this but
this this is now what religious freedom
is taken to mean that you can have a a
symbol of baffet or the devil on display
and you have a right to that in a
government building if you're a normal
person you probably have a problem with
this now some some of you might not some
of you might say oh whatever it's dumb
it's silly the satanic temple they were
just a bunch of edgy Reddit tier
atheists anyway who cares what they want
to do I don't like it I don't want my
country to exalt satanic symbols I think
that's bad I don't want shrines to Satan
in my government buildings